[موسيقى]
مثل
المحطه في معركه الانتخابات التمهيديه
للحزب الجمهوري اطلقت بانس حملته
الانتخابيه انتقد الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن
ووصف رئاسته بالكارثيه لكن الهجوم الاعنف
وجهه لترامب متهما اياه بتعريض حياته
وحياه عائلته للخطر يوم الهجوم على
الكونجرس في السادس من يناير
يجب ان يعلم الشعب الامريكي وانا قاده
الحزب الجمهوري سيحافظون على قسمهم
بالدفاع عن الدستور حتى عندما
لا يكون صحتهم السياسيه وان اي شخص يجعل
نفسه فوق الدستور او يطلب من الاخرين
اعلاءه فوق القانون الاساسي للبلد لا يجوز
ان يكون رئيسا مره اخرى
اخر انضم لقائمه المرشحين انه كريس كريستي
حاكم ولايه نيوجي السابق الذي كان مقربا
من ترامب الى ان فطرت علاقتهما خلال جائحه
كورونا ومن قبله نيكي هيلي سفيره الولايات
المتحده السابقه لدى الامم المتحده في
مستهل اداره ترامب فيما يظل حاكم ولايه
فلوريد الذي اعلن ترشحه قبل فتره الاقدر
على تهديد ترامب في هذا السباق
[موسيقى]
اغلب الرؤساء يترشحون لرئاسه ثانيه او لا
يترشحون بعد خسارتهم لذا من غير المعتاد
ان يدخل رئيس سابق كدونالد ترامب السباق
وهذا ما يمنح نائبه السابق فرصه لمنافسته
والامر الثاني غير المعتاد هو الذي لم
يمانع صدوره تافات عنيفه من مناصره بحق
بانس يوم اقتحام الكونغرس لذا ليس غريبا
ان يترشح بانس ضده
الرغبه وفره المرشحين والتحقيقات المتعدده
التي تلاحق ترامب ما زال الرئيس السابق
يتصدر استطلاعات الرايب بتساعد دائره
منافسيه ترامب لنيل لقب مرشح الحزب
الجمهوري للرئاسه لعام 2024
يعد هذا الصيف بمعركه محتدمه بينما اعتاد
عليه ترامب من هجمات لاذعه على خصومه
ومساعي مقربين سابقين منه لاضعاف مكانته
في السباق قبيل توجه الناخبين لصناديق
الاقتراع مطلع العام المقبل بسبب كويك
الجزيره واشنطن